know I had no love in my life I had no
purpose in my life
[Music]
yeah I'm just trying to get my little
piece to work that's it just trying to I
ain't trying to change the world or just
that's really pretentious I'm just
trying to get my little piece right
that's it
but in so doing you're not trying to be
a better person I mean that's the goal
right it's like what you know it's what
are you striving for you know you wind
up somewhere in the middle
my purpose in life I mean the only real
thing I'm good at is like bearing my
soul so
somewhere in there is a purpose thinks
it can be quite um
healing to have somebody else open up
for you
I think it can be like a healing thing I
think when this stuff is done right it
can be more than just a shallow
objectified
existence you can actually be quite
helpful to people
I know I've had performers help me in my
life who I've never met so
I don't know to be helpful I guess
there's something pure about a person
who just comes in and gives
and then try to take nothing you know
and sometimes a selfie sometimes feels a
bit like a take
sometimes not all the time it's all in
like the approach you know if they're
asking questions just to get to the
selfie you can feel it
yeah if you're having an actual dialogue
about something everybody's into it and
then that comes up at the end that
doesn't seem like as much as of a take
I grew up on a in a culture
that told me going to war made you a man
going to prison and coming back coming
back makes you a man making a million
dollars makes you a man you know and and
it doesn't and you don't know it till
you didn't done all these things and
realize damn I'm still a little [ __ ]
boy my definition of warrior has changed
me too you know I didn't really know
what that meant and really it's about
bringing the others back and that's my
whole [ __ ] mission I think we're all
nostalgic right now that's why we like
sequels so much and you know it's why
that's just that's our culture
yeah uh I can't control the lines or
anything past me yeah this is my attempt
to like
um reintegrate myself into society
because even if you never get there
there's something really instructive uh
or incisive about living as if right
like uh like I pray at night when I'm
scared even though science tells me
there's no God
but I still pray
I don't know why it's just something I
do and I feel like I'm a better person
because of it I know God's like a not a
good topic in this room but you know I
mean no I don't believe in him and or
her or it and yes I do I don't identify
with that school of thought really I
don't really know what I do or what
where where it comes from or how it
happens I know that I I feel a whole lot
I got a big heart I don't know if I'm a
method guy and I think some of that
stuff's ridiculous it's like kind of the
staying in character that's sort of the
class I like to be immersive yeah I like
all immersive experience not just acting
it's probably why I like Catholicism as
well I like all immersion I like being
fully I like Adventure and that requires
like full immersion so I would consider
myself an immersive actor but method
acting has like a bad smell to it some
of the penitence involved in method is
interesting because then you're not
acting I hate acting I hate acting
because it feels like like you can get
it wrong when you're really in it
um then you can't get it wrong I hate
losing you know I like to win and so
there's ways to like backstop a
performance where you leave yourself
very little room for error if you're in
the middle of it if you show up with all
the Caps it's it's easier to to believe
and uh that you're a part of that
because you showed up with it equally if
you're playing a gangster and you roll
in with gangsters it feels the same way
whereas
um the make-believe stuff feels like
frivolous and unintrinsic and like
wishy-washy it activates something in me
where it feels like I found something
it's a little bit like a band when a
band is pushed on you you it doesn't
feel the same way as you finding it when
you find it then you root for it it
feels like this special thing that you
found and you protect it and you hold it
and it's yours when somebody's selling
me on something it somehow takes my it
kills the the my aptitude for it and my
suspension of disbelief and my yearnings
to root for it you know my my whole my
opinion about God before this happened
before the pain struck before my world
had crumbled was Art love and God they
all mean the same thing they're
synonymous and as an artist who creates
art I found myself in a Godly position
often right where I was in charge and I
had also been told my whole life like
your life is your life you have to make
with it what you can you know you got to
be a good guy and then you got to get
married and then you got to get a house
and you got to get a job and do good at
your job and like your life is your life
and things will work out if you put
effort in and you know um it's up to you
and I always really felt that and it
made it hard to believe in God because
it felt like my managerial skills are
what are going to amount to fulfilled
existence yeah when all of my designs
failed when all of my plans went out the
window when my life had led to Serious
infliction of pain and damage on other
people I threw up my hands like my plans
are garbage and I don't want to be here
anymore that's I guess another thing
that I love about Catholicism it takes
me out of like all this cognitive
um like I have to do this fairy tale
make believe and it puts it right there
like I can touch it you know I don't
need to wonder whether a saint exists
when I'm looking at his heart when I'm
looking at his when they're when you
have all these talismans of like what
this actual like physical Mana of what
was there for a person who's this
caveman as I am in terms of I need a
Polaroid picture
I need a Polaroid picture of God
Catholicism offers it to me old me used
to like live on a set you know I would
like live in a tank yeah and I'd be
living in the tank and like doing all
this extra like extra blah blah blah
because I was so scared that I wasn't
going to get it right that I didn't want
to leave any room for error I had no
faith in anything other than my own will
my own efforts and then you get to this
set it's
um
you can only go so far and then you
really do have to have faith because
you're you're it's not like you're um
you're not playing anything you can
actually rationalize I had no love in my
life I had no purpose in my life my
whole purpose as you know was just craft
it was just I'm gonna be good at this
thing and that's all that I have the
only thing I care about in life is being
a good actor and that's such a vapid
shallow existence and three emotions
that I toggle between which was I would
feel
um
anxiety depression and excitement and I
thought excitement was joy and I thought
lack of depression was Serenity peace
yeah and I had no spiritual life I had a
very
I was bankrupt spiritually I thought my
whole my whole spirituality was this
craft
because other than smoking weed and
drinking the only spiritual experience I
ever felt was on set
you know that's the only time my
perspective would shift and change and
it's the only time I ever felt useful
and so um I'm on a spiritual growth path
I'm on a uh an excavation I'm picking it
up cleaning it up putting it back you
know you can't
make amends for permanent damage like
that you know and so
my daughter now has become this
opportunity for me you know and every
woman in my purview has become an
opportunity for me to be like a stand-up
dude
I used to open doors for women I used to
you know I was a good dude that way but
it was almost performative it was almost
like I'll do this good thing so you can
think I'm a good dude I'm making contact
communication little by little you know
it's only been 597 days I'm still at the
beginning of this whole journey in my
life which is going to be for the rest
of my life and um and yeah I go to every
single person out in harmed and I try to
figure out where I can be of service to
their life in any way that's that's
possible